what samulet is doing is provide
providing visibility providing the
security professionals and the companies
an understanding of what is the current
security posture what is the current
risk level from security gaps that they
have in their organization boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake and we are still at
cough as the Congress on the future of
engineering software for our second
annual partnership with them we are now
with Iran around its hello yeah they're
coming on to the show
nice meeting it really appreciate it and
Iran just won the startup competition at
Co Fez yeah innovation competition
innovation companies innovation
technology yeah yeah yeah and we just
won that is super cool and we're gonna
be talking about his company simulate
and samuel 8 is doing breach and attack
simulation how secure organization is
assessing different attack vectors and
he was previously at Microsoft three
years and they're just a really cool
journey that we're gonna be unpacking
here so tell us about this journey how
did you end up becoming who you are
today you know Alan it's it's a good
question it's a it's a long journey I've
actually started in security back in
2007
if I'm not mistaken I worked at a
company that did malware detection and
malware stopping I took a break came
back to security in secure Islands we
had a very cool tool for security
orchestration we sold this to Microsoft
which is now part of Microsoft
information protection and in Microsoft
I was in different roles global black
belts the experts of security for
Microsoft I've cyber solution group a
very good group that is focusing on the
top strategic customers of Microsoft
helping our customers to understand
what is the journey that Microsoft is
doing in security versus what they need
and how to combine these two needs in
the last role I really was part of
product strategy team I think in
Microsoft and then Simon late approached
me with this cool technology and the
reason that I've decided to go to
Microsoft from Microsoft to simulate
he's really based on the journey that I
had so lots of professional security
professionals that I was I've been
spoken to across the globe regardless of
the verticals whether its financials
banking industry insurance manufacturing
healthcare really you name it law
whatever is needed it's where privacy is
needed where security is important and
let's face it where it isn't today all
of these professionals I've sold them so
many different types of technologies but
they all had the same challenges
understanding how effective are they or
yeah I understand the need in in this
but I don't have the budget from the
board they don't really understand what
I need why I need this and when the
founder of Samuel 8al Vox man approached
me and he is the guy that I knew in the
past and he told me about this
technology and about platform
I said yes this is something that
customers do you need so I jumped ship
from this amazing company that is called
Microsoft and I came back to the startup
world to be innovative and really to
provide customers with some cutting-edge
technologies around cyber and yep so now
let me take a guess I was gonna take a
guess
the uneducated guessed correct so is
this this sort of you potentially set up
a very strong security for your for your
precious data or information and then
the security is then you run simulated
attacks on the security and then
wherever the the stress points are you
build those up you kind of have
potentially machine learning to learn
about where the stress points are build
up I will explain was I it was a ten
percent twenty four zero I would say
thirty percent that's okay yeah it's not
the bet yeah well you haven't heard
about the product yet yeah yeah yeah so
organizations today security
professionals security organizations and
again regardless of the size of the
organization or the vertical everyone is
spending a lot of effort in securing
their organization you know every
organization to their extend to their
limit of resources and budget but
everyone is buying what they think is
best for their so for their organization
in order to secure them from
cyberattacks whether the reason is to
steal data or to basically stop
production of these companies so
security is really top of mind for any
of course security professionals but
chief information officers CEOs board of
directors risk officers it's stop of
mine because cyberattacks are real and
cyber attacks are happening on a daily
basis in the day that we are now
recording this
we basically heard that this is record
breaking a record-breaking day from the
perspective that the most the largest
amount
of Records have been leaked to billion
records to billion or two billion
records private information of
individuals and professionals we're
talking about email addresses we are
talking about thank God not Social
Security numbers but phone numbers
addresses mortgage information in some
cases so what are these records what was
this leak who by do we know so it's a
company that is doing verification for
marketing companies so the only huge
amount of data in few databases that
were compromised and who hacked into
those database I don't know at this
moment but this is yeah but this is
crazy all that yeah there's tons of
these the Publishing's of cyberattacks
and just cyber war in general such an
insane field that is that has constant
geopolitical pressure is all over it and
yeah and corporate pressure from across
countries and even inside of countries
so just for example off magnitude of
what is the impact of such cyberattacks
just 20 days ago norsk hydro it's an
aluminum Factory in Norway got hit with
ransomware in the past 20 days they've
analyzed the amount of damage that it
cost them so far
20 days it's around 40 million dollars
then it's much cheaper to pay you to
help prevent this from happening so I'm
not preventing but what Samuel 8 is
doing is provide providing visibility
providing the security professionals and
the companies an understanding of what
is their current security posture what
is their current risk level from
security gaps that they have in their
organization their posture and the
security posture how well they're
positioned exactly - to fight fend off
those exactly
and one of the things that is extremely
important today is to have a repeatable
process in order to increase your
security posture and this repeatable
process is requiring a platform a tool
that will continuously automatically and
customizable and fully customizable to
execute these attacks in order to
understand where is our security gaps to
assess them and prioritize them the
prioritization is usually done half by
the solution and half by the security
professional because we know what the
risks are but we don't know what is the
business of the customer and the
combination of these really provides
where the major risk are and we also
provide recommendations how to mitigate
is up to the enterprise to mitigate
whether it's to change configuration
change work process or buy a new
solution or a better solution than what
they currently have do and then validate
it so it's a circle process a repeatable
process that is required by by various
security frameworks today at risk
frameworks do you guys have like 12
points or something do you have a
certain amount of points that show that
you know this would be the ideal
security posture and like you have these
twelve points and then if they say any
then so it's a good question when you
are looking at a cyber attack or what we
call a modern cyber attack or advanced
persistent threat in the security lingo
it basically have three steps one step
the first step is the infiltration the
front door step how an attacker
infiltrates the organization the second
step is the actual exploitation so the
attacker is in they need to get hold off
an endpoint and then there is the
process that is called
lateral movement this is the post
exploitation in the lateral movement the
attacker is trying to get to high valued
assets in the organization whether it's
files emails databases and basically
gain domain domination through getting
admin password on the domain controllers
and the last stage is either flattening
the organization using ransomware or
anything else but also data exfiltration
let's assume the attacker doesn't really
even want to be unknown that there is an
attack just to find the information and
exfiltrated and what samulet is doing we
have divided this attack kill chained to
seven different vectors and we are
testing the security controls in each
and every one of them and providing the
risk score for each and every one of
these interesting so you test the
organization's security yourselves
corrector your own attacking of their
security to see how well they do exactly
so organizations have email security
controls web gateways security controls
DLP solutions endpoint solutions we are
basically attacking these solutions we
are challenging these solutions in a
capture the flag game once we're done
once we are in we have captured the flag
we know exactly what was the method that
we have used and we're actually mapping
this to a common now common practice of
mapping this to the mitre attack
framework it's an organization that is
doing some mapping of attack
technologies in order to help
organizations really increase and
enhance their security posture one
interesting thing that we're doing in
addition to this is our constant
research our research team is constantly
researching new attacks so whenever
there is a new attack in the wild that
we heard of
we're actually looking and we're working
with international certs and other
companies to get some insights on this
attack and we are immediately
implementing this attack into our
solution so that a day or two days after
the attack has happened
you can already test yourself am i
protected against this and this norsk
hydro that I've mentioned before
basically a day after the attack
happened
you already had this version of
attacking our solution and you would be
able to check for yourself
whether you have protected or not
correct so you're constantly learning
just like in autonomous vehicles
learning from the decisions that it's is
being made as it's driving and then
updating the network of cars similarly
to yeah what you guys are doing so it's
not an automated process there's a lot
of human expertise that is needed there
for me in order to reverse engineer
these attacks and build them in a non
malicious way into the solution into the
solution yeah because when we are
attacking an organization we don't want
to cause any harm yeah it's really light
really no impact on the environment on
the production environment so it really
acquires light touch and an expert touch
form or team of engineers and
researchers yeah you work with the
organization's top security and then you
work with them on making sure that the
way that you're using samuli on their
their walls of security is a way that is
agreed upon by both parties that you're
gonna yep it's it's very light it's all
of our customers we never had a problem
of hey we you caused damage into our
production environment you're just
strengthening the walls your strengths
again I'm giving them the visibility to
test first of all there are security
controls test they're mole walls and
moats walls and moats yeah yeah yeah
their walls moats interesting what are
the seven attack vectors so you look at
email so one of
the main methods for attacking an
organization the getting into the front
door of passing the front door is
through three main mechanisms email web
pages that contain malicious content or
web application that an attacker is
attempting attempting to compromise and
take advantage of a web server and
execute remote commands so we're looking
at the email protection we're looking at
the web gateway filtering system and the
Web Application Firewall we're
challenging them you probably heard
about phishing phishing and spear
phishing phishing is a method that is
designed to either do two things either
trick a person to open malicious content
inside the email or direct them to the
to a malicious web page so we are
testing the email security yeah to
understand if a malicious payload was
god were brought in or the web filtering
gateway whether a user that accidentally
clicks on a link from a phishing email
will go and reach malicious web site
that contains malicious content and we
also have phishing mechanism inside our
solution so these are the four front
door pre exploitation attack vectors or
attack surfaces yes the next one the
exploitation one is really the endpoint
so once the attacker got in he needs to
execute some malicious code on the
endpoint so we're looking at the
endpoint protection solution and we are
looking at what we call an ad our
endpoint detection and response solution
basically to challenge them whether they
are protecting against the attacks that
we have worms Trojans
ransomware attacks and the more standard
malware and anti viruses after this we
have the lateral movement where the
attacker is moving throughout the
organization to find high-value assets
and this is where we are challenging the
user and entity behavior analytic
solutions or the same solution security
incident event management solution of
the customer we even challenge their own
Sauk team so the Security Operations
Center to be able to detect whether
something is happening yeah
and the last attack vector or attack
surface is really to exfiltrate
information out so yeah let's assume
I've done everything and now I've found
this type of information whether it's
images or CAD drawings or files which
contain sensitive information on mergers
and acquisitions and financials to try
and send this information outside so
these are the seven main vectors and we
have this immediate threat vector that
we call it or a module that basically
combines both the email the endpoint and
the web gateway that you can actually
test new types of attacks new threats
that are coming and this is what we are
adding almost on a daily basis now so
then the the when you when you do add
this in to a company then they they they
you're simultaneously testing out their
security posture and you're also helping
consult with them on making those fixes
to their security yeah so we basically
identify the security gaps and part of
the solution is also to provide product
agnostic recommendations on how to
mitigate these yes
and it's up to the enterprise to take
these results and these recommendations
and either do some configuration changes
or work process changes or to go and
seek a different and new solution that
addresses these problems okay this these
reports are then also used in order to
let's assume I need to get more budget
from my manager or the security so now
how do we reflect the security go the
security gap the risk it's not a
subjective statement it's not an
assumption yeah it's a proof it's a
hardware officer report based on an
attack simulation that we have executed
and then you can actually have the
agnostic recommendation for the fix and
then you have an exact monetary amount
that you need to to fix the security so
we are not getting into the monetary
stuff it's but we are a recommendation
yeah yeah yeah it's up to the security
professional to go and seek the
assistance of their security partner
security consultant company but then
it's not it's not an abstract number for
them anymore it's an actual like you
said hard exact data and they can
actually present this is exactly how
much money we also need to fix it so
it's like so it's a it's very
interesting I have a couple I have a
couple other thoughts for you one of
them is let's let's talk about the the
role of of what your how you program the
those those attack vectors like how do
you send a a an attack on an on a click
a controlled attack on an organization
yeah so you know it's a very good
question and it's very scary questions
for people that are listening to a
attack simulation what would be the
impact on my productive production
environment so let me put you in ease
it's a cloud service and from the
perspective of so there are two types of
attacks one is external
and one is internal from external we're
looking at the sending the emails or
attacking the Web Application Firewall
challenging the Web Application Firewall
the rest of the attacks are done from
the inside so we have an agent that you
need to install it's in any size of
organization you install anything
between one agent and 15 agents but
these are the numbers we're talking
about we're not talking about hundreds
or thousands or the entire organization
and we're doing this usually except one
case on a non production machines
because you need to remember what we are
challenging is not your actual IT
environment we are challenging your
security controls on the IT environment
so you can give me any machine a non
production machine but you have all of
your security controls around it and I
will challenge them with whatever file
you want on the inside yeah exactly
so I'm not disrupting the actual
day-to-day work of the organization so
that's really with no impact to the
organization nor how no harm is done
very smart so you basically take all the
security infrastructure from the company
put it on to something that has none of
the impact on the company and then you
do your tax simulation on that and
exactly that's great yeah that makes a
lot it's usually called golden image or
golden images okay where they where
there's a new employee for example and
they need to give a computer to a new
employee then they upload the golden
image into this endpoint and then they
already have all of their security
controls or endpoint and you install our
agent on an endpoint like this whether
it's a physical hardware or a virtual
machine and you can test the the
security posture much quicker with a
simulation potentially then if someone's
trying to manually go in and test yeah
all of the different so areas there's a
lot of penetration testing company
in the world and when you're looking at
this and a lot of companies are required
or want to do pen testing it's very
expensive to do pan testing so it
usually I'll gonna and it's very
thorough usually pen testing is very
thorough but very narrow yeah so the pen
tester is trying to penetrate for a
specific path the narrow is as possible
because they want to finalize the
penetration testing get the report and
continue what we're doing and we are
working with pen testers we're working
with partners that are fantastis and
adding our technology into their tools
so a pen tester company can actually
take our tool and use it in order to
have this broad attack against the
organization and then use the results to
fast understand how they can penetrate
so you get a much more elaborated pen
testing result and then you can offer
also to the organization to the
enterprise that hired you to actually
hey let's run this in a more continuous
method and not once a year or once a
quarter
interesting you also work with pen
testers and then how about on the on the
on the on the on the machine learning
side of things tell us about how you
leverage artificial intelligence and
what you're doing it seems like if
there's certain structural weaknesses
that you could potentially if you fail
at once maybe you up the up yeah up the
ante a bit you hit it again see what
yeah yeah so so I don't really like the
concept of AI in this okay but there's
definitely machine learning in the best
practices that we have okay
so I'll just give an example around this
so we have around the email testing
alone we have about 15,000 permutations
of malicious payloads that we can send
both crazy but the best practices that
we are
engaged is not sending all of these
because it's just waste of time because
if you are protected against something
specific then it doesn't make sense to
send four thousand examples of something
similar because you're probably already
protected so we're sending the first
fifty and we see what got in what got
out and what didn't what is blocked yeah
and then based on these results we'll
send another 50 or another 100 which
looks at a specific aspect that we were
able to penetrate basically once we're
in let's widen this hole and understand
how big this gap is so this is the
machine learning that we are using and
this is where it's really important to
also customize the attack you don't want
to just throw a tax in you want to
understand exactly what the attacks that
you're doing so let's take for example
you've probably heard of patching
Tuesday where the big companies are
releasing all the patch and now you
patch all of your machines so let's call
it ransomware Wednesday let's execute
attacks that imitates ransomware every
Wednesday interesting and I'll get a
result off mi protected against
ransomware every Wednesday and I know
how to mitigate this the attacks can be
customizable yeah yeah and then maybe
one of the last questions I want to ask
you is well I guess maybe maybe a couple
more but this one this one's very close
to to my heart it's like I feel as
though we're kind of heading towards a
global surveillance state yep and it
like that security and privacy have to
be at the highest level of cryptography
and all this kind of stuff because we
maybe haven't spiritually evolved yet if
we if we if we better collectively
evolved we might might not have some of
the malicious attackers all right and so
it almost seems as though we could have
went on a way of complete trust and
transparency but in a way with all the
fortunate circumstances that we have as
well as fortunate once we're heading
towards a place of needing this very
high security and very high privacy do
you align with that unfortunately we do
need to evolve ourselves and the way we
were thinking and the way we are
handling our data and our identity and
this is because of rogue organizations
and I'm not talking about rogue States
I'm talking about criminal organizations
that are using our data for their own
needs selling our data and the market
the black market or stolen data is is
massive so I'm doing this with myself
and of course my wife we need to make
sure that our data is secure we need to
make sure that our identity is secured
we need to use two-factor authentication
and one of the things that I would love
to have as much as possible from
government organizations so basically
any company that holds our data is to
only allow access to this data based on
two-factor authentication or other new
methods of identification it's also
called to factor but facial recognition
is something now that most of the people
have in their cell phones or a
thumbprint reader in the cell phone and
this is something that I really
encourage every person if you are you
have an identity in a website whether
it's Amazon Facebook Microsoft Google
any government website that allows
two-factor authentication
please enable this this is extremely
important for your information yeah yeah
yeah and we're you know we're at we're
at Co Fez were here with you know on
behalf of of engineering software and
the importance of that where do you see
I'm Samuel Eights role in engineering
software so so that's a great question
Ellen
and when it came here I had doubts I
have to say I'm not from the engineering
space but talking to all these smart
people in the industry
I figure out something that I probably
should have thought about it beforehand
there's a lot of intellectual property
yeah and it it can be in the small
companies that they are developing new
technologies new innovative technologies
it can be in the small technology
companies that are developing for the
large ones and of course the large
companies lots of information
intellectual property that they need to
protect and again I'm sure their
security teams are spending the budget
in order to secure themselves mm-hmm
to the best of their knowledge but the
problem is that the knowledge then the
best of their knowledge is based on
assumptions and not based on true facts
and simulate is the tool that will
provide them with this visibility of
what is their effectiveness of their
security solution how they are where
they are most vulnerable will give them
a platform to do this repeatable process
will give them the ability to understand
whether they are protected from new
threats and one thing that is extremely
important especially for the large
companies how their supply chain is
secured yeah so this is something that
we are considering now and we started
talking with some companies about how
their supply chain is being tested for
security you know and this is something
that they can use in order to do so
it's regardless of the fact that this is
engineering software convention every
company needs to be able to protect
their assets there are high valued
assets yeah
we help them with that yeah yeah and the
last question would be you know we're
heading into this exponential technology
age what would you say is if not the
most important skill set for kids and
for adults to learn well you know it's
it's an amazing question and as having
kids of my own I think that stem is is
very important I would love to see more
I would love to see more girls also
doing stem so science technology
engineering and mathematics but what I
would love to see kids today is actually
talking with each other and not texting
yeah you know the Millennials yeah yeah
this has been so enlightening really I'm
loving what you're putting its forth
with with with with simulate like it's
just it's simulating attacks to bring up
defense and to bring up privacy and
security it's just it's very fascinating
yeah congratulations on winning to that
Thank You Alan yeah this has been such a
pleasure um thank you so much and thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate check out the links below to
samuel 8 also check out the links below
to Co Fez let us know your thoughts in
the comments we'd love to hear from you
share more of these conversations with
the people around you and your
communities online with your family and
friends coworkers also check out the
links to Co faz as well and also support
the artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe it support us support simulation
below and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thanks for tuning in and we will
see you soon
peace thank you